well well well reject nation
looks like warren the cosmic wonders
chair giveaway has officially been
awarded
that's right people we took it away from
the subscribe now that's that'd be
messed up we just bought a chair
ourselves anyway
spider warren has put out another video
from spiderman himself
tom holland teases spiderman trailers
soon
spiderman no way home trailer update mr
humphrey has stepped out looks like it's
just you and i yes snooze you lose
right john don't think i didn't watch
that video from last week
[Music]
hey what's up everyone uh i just wanted
to take a second
thank you uh you know everyone sent me
amazing messages
some people did some lovely artwork some
people sent me letters
so i just wanted to say thank you uh it
really really means a lot
uh i had a wonderful birthday i was with
all my mates and it was really fun
and it was even better because all of
you guys were there with me
so thank you so much i really appreciate
that sexy here and i'll see you soon
hopefully i'll have some cool stuff to
show you some spider-man stuff so i'm
gonna try and stuff soon
which will be cool but i am yeah i
really really appreciate it
get back there
what's going on everybody it's warren
and welcome back to the cosmic wonder
okay all right so he's teasing that
we're gonna get some spider-man stuff
and then someone saw
obviously we're gonna get something of
both of them like
getting a little bit more actual stuff
from uncharted
lately let's face it you know i think if
sony wants to play their cards they want
to be smart about this if they just put
out uncharted will it get a lot of views
will it get a lot of attention
absolutely it will but there will be a
lot of people i bet those comp boxes
will be filled with
okay but where's the spider-man trailer
and i feel like more people will be much
more on board to watch that uncharted
trailer even though we're gonna watch it
regardless but you know how youtube
comment boxes can be people are gonna
want to watch the spider-man trailer
first before seeing that uncharted
trailer even though they've been
releasing
like what looks like more actual promo
images of uncharted
anyway that's a sweet little message
from tom hall and see what the trailer
updates all about
and as you just saw from tom holland
himself not only does he thank everybody
for wishing him a happy birthday
but he gave us a little tease saying
that hopefully he can show us some
spider-man stuff
pretty soon and it looks like pretty
soon could actually
be next week there is a lot of
speculation about the 10th right now
with some decent evidence to back it up
now of course like i mentioned in a
couple of my videos here we go
here we go pictures stating that the
trailer will indeed drop on june 10th
however the picture hasn't been
confirmed real but it also hasn't been
confirmed
fake yet pictures are always tricky
because people can photoshop
very very well and i personally learned
my lesson for the venom 2 trailer
there was a lot of great photoshop work
done for the venom to let there be
carnage trailer stating that it was
coming out a certain day when in reality
it wasn't because it was photoshopped
but that is a fun day this june 10th
trailer release date on right now
somebody who is very reputable came out
and has stated that
he heard it is indeed going to be on
june 10th
and based off of what we've heard so far
and some things that i've personally
heard
this seems like it could be very
legitimate and could be the day we are
getting the trailer
okay before we go into ever the sources
that he's talking about i want to just
ask you guys do any of you
at all enjoy the fun trolling that
happens i know it pisses off a lot of
people and especially as
someone who like does all this every
single day who's often like oh my god do
i have to get up at five in the morning
the next day and then you get some
anxiety and stress over just making sure
you're on top of
having to cover a specific trailer it
can stress me out at the same time
there's this other part of my brain that
goes it's
pretty funny just how much ridiculous
that's
trolling every going on i know it can be
annoying for people and i
completely 100 understand the feeling
believe me i've had my messages back and
forth with other youtubers warren
included wait wait
i heard this i heard this i heard this i
guess the part that makes it amusing and
humorous to me
is the fact that it's making the trailer
when it actually does come feel even
more eventful however i know there's a
large portion of the population that
could really just do without any of that
trolling for starters
as i mentioned this person josh thanos
webb did state that the trailer is
dropping
june 10th he's got this got a check mark
ability if it didn't drop that day
now josh is a staff writer at the marvel
report which is a marvel
news website twitter instagram etc he's
putting his reputation on the live
sports and his work has been featured on
espn
nbc cbs and more okay
and recently somebody asked him on
twitter about the no way home trailer in
which he replied
trailer drops june 10th and then of
course a lot of people were asking him
how he knew
this information if he was basing it off
of that amc picture
if he was basing it off of some fake
youtube channels that have been created
in which he actually replied and said
i'm definitely not basing it on a
youtube channel
this is what i was told by somebody who
told me about
far from home they were absolutely dead
on with far from home they told me the
post credit scenes
the plot twist and that jk simmons was
returning i love
super so much i heard from this person
this person or from this person this
came with telephone this is so amusing
i feel like i've heard of him in the
past he's got the check mark he's like
really putting his reputation on the
line because there are people who like
do scoops when they
become that declarative about something
that's a lot of confidence being willing
to take
the responsibility of you know what it
didn't come out
i know this affects me and i'll have to
earn the trust back from you guys even
though some people doesn't matter
they'll still follow them anyway so
listen whatever they got to say
wow all right josh thanos webb looks
like um
planning for a very long 48 hours from
loki to the spider-man trailer let's do
it marvel and i
actually remember this i remember going
to the theaters thinking i've heard what
the two post credit scenes are
i wonder if they're real and they were
for far from home so the credibility
seems like it's there and then of course
like i mentioned in some other videos
i have personally heard that the trailer
is indeed at the theaters
and from what i've been told by people
in the industry they only do this when
they are preparing to actually release
it they don't put this this trailer
is once in advance they only send
trailers to theaters if it's weeks away
from
not months and the trailer has been in
theaters for about a week now maybe a
little bit more
which means june 10th is a very
plausible date
now of course this isn't confirmed i'm
just doing an update on everything that
i've heard so far however this does seem
like it very well could happen
especially since today tom holland came
out and said that hopefully he can show
us some spider-man no way home stuff
soon soon coming into account that many
weeks from now
junket is on monday the 7th and loki
releases on the 9th
we could assume that the trailer won't
come monday through wednesday
however they could release it that
thursday to promote loki even further
and to help loki promote spider-man no
way home as well hopefully that is the
case hopefully we don't have to wait
longer than june 10th
it does seem like it's happening very
soon they like the marvel momentum
training but of course we'll have to
wait to find out so be sure to subscribe
and hit that notification bell so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
thank you warren no way home cool
updates and let me know how excited you
are for the spiderman no way home
trailer in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching we'll follow up
awesome just
itching for it you know ah you can just
feel it it's like i just wanna see it i
am gonna be putting out a video
um that i have bullet points for just
gonna be going off the dome for it it's
different it's gonna be different from
regarding to spiderman no way home
you'll see
just turn up subscribe hit that
notification bell it would be kind of a
cool little interesting conversation to
have with
all you guys as well i'm gonna be very
curious to know what you guys comment on
what the feedback is
in that video guys subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell hit
that like button
thank you so much for being here and of
course subscribe to cosmic wonder
great friend of mine last but not least
flev doran flev um i just wanted to say
a sincere thank you you've been like
such an understanding
follower of ours for uh such a long time
and
you're always so inquisitive you love to
give like just really
in-depth feedback and you're someone
who's just so
fascinating to to get to know i remember
like when we first started messaging
each other you would act like
that you might not be that much of an
interesting person it's like kind of the
vibe i think you actually set that
straight up getting to know you i think
that
the conversation flow that we can have
back and forth with each other
is something i'm always very much and
dear to and look forward to i know i
haven't been able to really respond
lately it's just been a lot of you know
busy it's been
but i really do appreciate how
supportive
you are uh you're someone that whenever
i see your name
a little bit of joy just pops into my
heart and a genuine smile just comes
across my face so
thank you so much for being youthlev and
uh hopefully we
one day meet in person because you seem
like you just be an awesome individual
thank you buddy
[Music]